saviez-vous qu'il existe 7 merveilles au
Portugal des merveilles gastronomiques
parmi elles on retrouve les sardines
bien sûr les fameuses pastels des Natas
mais également une soupe moins connue
mais tout aussi savoureuse le caldo
Verde ou bouillon vert vert comme
le chou on prend n'importe quelle sorte
de chou moi je prends le collant celle
là
ça c'est des feuilles entier une fois
que tes mincés ça ressemble à ceci voilà
je reconnais exactement c'est ça donc
après ça on met dans la soupe et ça fait
un bocal d'eau verte
on va aller cuisiner ça ce beau chou la
chef d'origine portugaise ni lades Silva
inscrit toujours lequel d'ouverté à la
carte de son restaurant aldea et
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette recette de
cadeau Verde
traditionnelle en fait qui vient de nord
du Portugal tous les maisons portugais
et en train de calde Auvergne il y a
juste quelques ingrédients comme des
pommes de terre un oignon de gousses
d'ail les chorizo qui se qui dans le
goût aussi le sel
une recette populaire qui est au menu
des célébrations de la Sao Joao la
Saint-Jean-Baptiste portugaise
[Musique]
les cales c'est très populaire dans la
Saint-Jean aussi alors
vous nous dites que c'est simple mais on
veut vous croire sur parole comment
comment on procède quand on fait un quel
gouverneur
on coupe les patates et on le ajoute
on ajoute l'oignon qu'on a coupé
quelques temps un peu de sel un petit
peu de Bouillante poulet l'huile d'olive
et voilà
une fois qu'on atteint les bullition on
ajoute le chorizo et on laisse cuire 30
minutes nail art retire le saucisson
avant de passer le tout au mélangeur
le chou en cerceau comment de quelle
façon à l'école normalement elle sert
dans une soupière d'argile aussi on
accompagne avec du vin du vin rouge et
du penis c'est le tradition à la fin
pour donner une touche finale on ajoute
un nœud une petite rondelle de chorizo
par dessus un peu comme une chips
c'est vraiment délicieux
j'adore cette soupe merci beaucoup nella
[Musique]
le violoniste des chefs d'orchestre
d'origine portugaise Alexandre Da Costa
est un fervent amateur de la cuisine de
son pays d'origine
et quand vient le temps de déguster une
cale de Verdet il sera chez son ami
Elena
[Musique]
et voilà
c'est quoi si vous aviez à décrire ce
type là c'est très simple en effet c'est
avec qu'est-ce qu'on avait plus
d'abondance dans le jardin c'est
vraiment les pommes de terre de l'ail
des oignons et les choux vous avez ça
toute l'année là c'est une soupe qu'on
peut la manger quand il fait chaud quand
il fait froid on l'aime tout le temps
mais vous qui êtes né au Québec qui vous
êtes d'origine portugaise bien entendu
mais lequel vous regardez ça représente
quoi pour vous mais moi en fait le
cadeau Verde je l'ai connu grâce à la
communauté portugaise de Montréal
j'étais assez jeune celui qui m'ont
donné mes premières opportunités de
faire des concerts à grande déploiement
à Montréal et puis après bien sûr après
chaque concert il y a un repas avec et
là c'est là où est-ce que toutes mes
papilles gustatives se sont réveillés en
même temps bon appétit
pour une soupe qui est chaude qui est
supposée à être été justement il y a ce
côté très Charlotte qui est une belle
combinaison
rouge avec un verre de vin blanc santé
vive la vie
de nous partager vos passions comme ça
merci pour le plaisir
[Musique]